I am the hope of the universe the I am
speech uh Namek it's one of the most
hotly contested and argued over scenes
found in Dragonball today designed as a
moment for Goku to proclaim that he the
legendary super saiyan has arrived the
scene itself has been reworked re-edited
and rewritten more times than I care to
count
resulting in some major differences
across various versions shown to us over
the years and so today I will be
focusing on and reviewing four of them
going in order of release I will first
take a look at the original manga
chapter from 1991 the original Japanese
broadcast from the same year followed by
the English Funimation editing dubbed
from 1999 capping it all off with Dragon
Ball Z Kai's redubbed version for the
year 2010 to round out our four options
but before I start reviewing and
breaking down the various versions of
the scene I'd like for you to vote here
in the top right and let me know what
your favorite version is before watching
the video why am i doing this before the
video well it's an experiment at the end
of the video I will give you another
chance to vote for your favorite version
of the scene and I want to see if your
preference has either stayed the same
or changed by the end and so with that
explained let's get the show rolling
with the very first time this legendary
scene hit the public eye and to do that
we need to go all the way back to April
2nd 1991 titled freezes first taste of
humiliation and despair this was written
and drawn entirely by Akira Toriyama
the cover art for this chapter sees a
focused and certain Super Saiyan Goku
looming over a smaller and frustrated
looking Frieza in the lower left corner
representing visually that Goku is now
the bigger threat to Frieza this being
the manga is the source material of the
events and is what every subsequent
iteration is derived from the chapter is
exactly 14 pages long taking up right
after Goku's transformation into a Super
Saiyan for the first time it begins as
Goku launches forward smashing Frieza
skull in with his elbow much like what
freezes did to him a few chapters prior
this further demonstrates how the tables
have turned between these two during his
assault
a tray street getting his composure but
what's happening is obvious Goku is
completely out classic him crushing his
back effortlessly blocking his blows and
dodging blast to the utter bewilderment
of Frieza damn him if I could just hit
him once
Goku's cam determined expression softens
to a smirk
he says hit me Frieza shocked and
insulted by the sans invitation grits
his teeth firing a powerful death beam
straight amount of Goku Frieza looks on
in shock never in his life has he
experienced something like this
he asks what what are you don't you
already know I am a Saiyan who came from
Earth to defeat you a warrior of legend
that has been awakened by anger but
possessing a calm heart erupts with
power Frieza initially speechless from
what he has just experienced and heard
eventually confesses I knew it this
truth to the legend after all he comes
to understand why Vegeta couldn't become
a Super Saiyan before crumbling to the
realization of the situation he has been
put in goku announces Frieza its own as
Goku begins to line up one final
comically ha Frieza interjects the likes
of you will never kill me I'd kill
myself first concern falls over Goku's
once composed demeanor as Frieza
launches his trump card a plan to remove
the atmosphere and air to defeat Goku
the final panel Frieza screaming and so
now that we know the source material
it's time for our first adaptation
original Japanese broadcast June 19 1991
airing only 10 weeks after the mangas
release of that very chapter titled an
explosion of anger Goku avenge
everyone's deaths the episode was
produced and animated by Toei animation
for the Japanese public first of all
let's talk filler a minor part of the
episode sees a side plot of Roshi yajuro
Pichichi and doctor briefs waiting and
working on a spaceship to help their
friends unnhhh emic the purpose of it
really is to have their opinions on what
is transpiring anomic before switching
back to the Canon material additionally
within the action between Goku and
Frieza there's even some filler action
despite the scene itself only taking
place within the final minutes of the
episode
[Music]
once the sobering feeling of what he has
gotten himself into begins to sink in
Frieza is forced to ask what the hell
are you as you are surely well aware I
am the Saiyan who has come from Earth to
defeat you despite my cam quiet heart I
am the legendary warrior awakened by
intense anger the speech is practically
one-to-one with the speech from the
manga
however visually there are some changes
instead of demonstrating the speech from
a three-quarter view front view and
medium-range upshot totally animation
opted for a front view of the speech
exclusively and while they finished the
scene with a medium up shot it too was
front done this can be seen as a
negative for some as it can make the
scene look flatter than it needs to be
however due to Dragon Ball being a
weekly show the nature and health of the
production schedule can lead to issues
like this during the show's run time on
the air
[Music]
and so with that covered let's look at
how the early Funimation dub measures up
original release October 19 1999 over
eight years after the original air date
in Japan folks in the West funding on
English dub of this scene however as I'm
sure most of you are aware this scene is
quite different from a dialogue
perspective titled explosion of anger
this interpretation of events is pretty
much one to one with the original
Japanese version visually however there
are a host of differences from a dialog
perspective this version of the scene
has become the root cause for this
particular debate among fans of the show
some love this scene above all other
versions and some don't but I want to
make one thing clear it's not wrong to
prefer any version over another we enjoy
what we enjoy with that said the
argument surrounds Goku's dialogue and
the way his character is portrayed for
example in the Japanese he says Mae amor
I am at the unison ISM the scene depicts
Goku as unforgiving he has snapped the
carefree Goku has given way to this more
aggressive and angry incarnation of the
character he even snaps at Gohan earlier
in the episode in the English version
they decide to reimagine the character
this is that same scene but in English
your evil deeds are like a noose around
your neck the script is going for a more
righteous interpretation of the Goku
character and nowhere is this more clear
than in the now-famous I am speech at
the end of this episode it reads I am
the hope of the universe I am the answer
to all living things that cry out for
peace
I am protector of the innocent I am the
light in the darkness I am truth
echoing in the background is the Bruce
Falconer score giving it a distinctive
atmosphere from its original version
which utilized the Kikuchi score both of
these respective soundtracks have
enormous fan bases that will vehemently
argue that their version is better than
all others and so with that one done and
out of the way let's jump forward to
Dragon Ball Kai original release
February 21st and November 17th 2010
entitled the angry Super Saiyan Goku
throws down the gauntlet this episode
was redubbed and released on the 21st of
February 2010 in Japan and later that
same year on November 17th in English
the driving forces behind the Dragon
Ball Kai Reed above the series was to
essentially have a recut streamlined
version of the original run of the
Dragon Ball anime aiming to could have
much of the filler portions to the story
were possible and in this particular
episode the filler scenes with Roshi and
the gang were removed however those
aren't the only differences so let's
focus on the dialogue the distinctions
between the Japanese dialogue and Kai
and the original broadcast while they
exist are minor at best and pretty much
remain as faithful as the original
Japanese broadcast ever did with the
same voice actors demonstrating
fantastic performances however there are
distinct changes to the English
redoubling of this scene having brought
themselves closer to the Japanese
version considerably for instance during
the 1999 Funimation dub portion of this
video I used this line from the episode
as an example your evil deeds are like a
noose around your neck again this is
very righteous and there's nothing wrong
with that but it's very different from
the original manga and so to compare
here is that exact line but redubbed in
English for Dragon Ball Kai
don't bother apologizing because I will
never forgive you as you might have
noticed this is closer to the mangas
interpretation of the character and
completely in line with what the
original Japanese broadcast wrote for
Goku and that's not where the
alterations end they two rewrote the
entire I am speech which reads I am the
same who came all the way from Earth
with the sole purpose of beating me
I am the warrior you've heard of in
legends pure of heart and awaken by fury
that's what I am
so before you guys give me your second
vote let's hear and compare the last
lines of each version let's do it don't
you already know I have a saying who
came from earth to defeat you a warrior
of legend awakened by anger for
possessing a calm heart and so as
promised this is where things get really
interesting now that I have broken down
the original manga chapter from 1991 the
original Japanese broadcast from the
same year the Funimation edit and dubbed
from 1999 and the Dragon Ball Kai
version from 2010 I would like to
present you with the opportunity to cast
your vote for a second time click here
and let us know which interpretation of
the events outlined you think presented
at best did your opinion change or did
it stay the same let me know in the
comment section down below I'm genuinely
really interested to see the results of
this video if you want to see more
videos like this one maybe subscribe I
upload every Thursday and don't forget
to leave a like' or dislike' in the
video thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you next week